first of all yes pink-purple 21 I know
I'm like a really extravagant cowboy you
know what I want
approach every awards show with the the
Flair of an extravagant how do you
approach what you're gonna wear on the
red carpet um honestly whatever makes me
feel really happy I'm like oh this one
look at this here's another question how
do you approach presenting an award to
Quentin Tarantino yet and also I just
found out I was he asked me to do this
yesterday and I was like already drunk I
was like oh no wait I need the next
bunch of hours to be anyway I'm very
excited I'm I'm probably I'm gonna speak
for too long because there's so much to
say oh my god I mean it's just amazing
the idea of having the two of you
together on stage anything in particular
that you learned from his list of movies
that you've taken into your own work
well he's made you know nine movies and
there every single one of them is a
piece of art from an auteur and I feel
like when you look at his body of work
it's just it's like the thing we all
measure ourselves against as film
artists well I mean look you've got your
own body of work but it's a pretty
amazing little women just unbelievable
how do you feel though about I mean I
feel like it's happening again this
awards season we're having this
conversation not enough female directors
being recognized
well what I'm what I'm heartened by is
how many beautiful films were directed
by women and what impact its making on
on the industry and they just came out
with another Annenberg study that said
there are more films this year directed
by women than any other year and it's
looking to improve again for 2020 and
then 20 21 so I just try to focus on the
glass half full of women
[Music]